what did you observe when you went back
into the penthouse
so the argument continued
there were moments of
kind of
normal conversation
peaceful conversation but then there
were also moments of
uh
yelling and
anger from from both of them um
and at some point i witnessed miss heard
throw a red bull camp so
the loft is three levels um
mr depp was down at the lower level
which is the kitchen area
there's a
middle level which is was turned into an
office for misheard
and then the
upper level
was where the bedrooms were but they
were turned into
a closet basically for misheard at that
time
um
miss heard and her sister at that time
um
whitney had had come in
they were both on the the middle level
the office level um
and i i saw miss heard throw a red bull
can
from her position um
that struck mr depp in the back
anything else that you recall
at that point i moved closer to mr depp
i didn't care um that i was
in the middle of their conversation at
that point i didn't want my client
getting hit with anything else so
i stood right by mr depp um
the verbal
uh
onslaught continued from from both of
them
mr depp was giving as good as he got at
that point
he was he was angry and agitated
um
at one point miss heard through
something else
either a purse or some sort of bag or
something that she had up there
um
i was able to knock it away so it didn't
hit him
at one point she spit
at him um
[Music]
yeah and then just just a lot of
a lot of verbal
vitriol from both of them
what do you remember miss heard saying
to mr depp on this occasion
geez
anything and everything um specifically
there was
the
you're washed up
um
uh which which he called her as well um
you're
again the the deadbeat dad
um
yeah i don't even remember what the
fight was about but it was um
it was pretty
the f word is my favorite word and
it was being thrown around
to the point where i was uncomfortable
you